thank you for joining us i'm john
langler as you know school is back in
session and clark county has been for
some time now but clark county school
district is still far from normal the
pandemic is still a weight on parents
students and teachers that stress and
the recovery the focus of congressional
testimony today by ccsd superintendent
dr jesus jarrah hector mejia live in the
newsroom with what was discussed hecker
well dr jarrah highlighted the way
federal funds have helped ccsd he went
over the challenges closing campuses
early on in the pandemic and then
reopening back in march
this is the u.s house of representatives
virtual subcommittee on early childhood
elementary and secondary education
superintendent dr jesus jarrah told
lawmakers ccsd included stakeholders
when it came to designing a
back-to-school plan including and our
five bargaining units representing 42
000 employees of the clark county school
district
together we instituted a mass mandate
and social distancing protocol however
he said they quickly discovered many
students had no internet or cell phones
at home in a matter of weeks we were
able to deploy over 247
000 devices and provide internet access
to the students who probably previously
did not have it ccsd has 304 000
students more than 70 percent on free or
reduced lunches dr jarrah also talked
about the staff shortages we need more
substitute teachers bus drivers
cafeteria workers and custodians all of
these vacancies are putting instruction
extracurricular activities and
maintenance of our district assets at
risk
we've learned ccsd began the school year
with almost 700 teacher vacancies when
it comes to vaccines the school board
recently gave dr jara the authority to
begin drafting a vaccine requirement for
all employees in our newsroom hector
mejia live local now